now I want to talk to you about relic
this is a scary movie it's a great it's
a great mood piece and it's it one of
the things that is I would think
difficult for an actor and your terrific
actor but I would think it would call
for you to be you're frightened almost
all the time and I would think that's
not easy as an actor it's very difficult
now it's very difficult I mean I find it
very easy to be scared in life I'm all
often scared in life but but to sustain
you know and you can manufacture it from
to a degree but to sustain that level of
fear for sort of four weeks straight is
it's quite exhausting and quite
pressings yep just keep conjuring up all
these terrible sort of thoughts and
feelings what kind of things are you
conjuring up like I've you know I've got
a zoom in cross across the pond with
Conan O'Brien that kind of rock terror
it is clear actually chat shows are one
of my biggest fear along with rats and
fear flying I have a preternatural
terror of chat shows and I do think of
them when I'm running down corridors in
horror films I could see yeah I could
see you I see the association between
going on talking to a talk show host and
encountering a rat I'm surprised you say
that because I was talking to someone
today and I told them that that I was
gonna be talking to you you're one of my
favorite people to talk to you because
you're so natural you're always yourself
and you're always funny and entertaining
so I don't I don't imagine you of all
people getting worried before you do
something like this well you know what I
think those are the reason that maybe if
I am good to do is because I'm so sort
of desperate to please that I will sell
my grandmother basically for a joke and
so that makes me sometimes quite a good
subject but it often leaves me feeling
slightly Hollow and sort of ashamed
afterwards not when I speak to you ever
you made me feel good about terrible
things I reveal about myself you know
why I think that's true I think it's
true because you and I are kindred
spirits
I will sell
anybody down the river if it's gonna get
me a laugh the only difference is I
don't feel horrible afterwards you're a
better person than I am that you have
that feeling afterwards I am a true
sociopath big laugh at the expense of
grandmother did I make it that often
there at the expense of myself which is
mostly fine but there are moments where
it's like oh I shouldn't have done that
I've got a bit far this time I did that
once with her I'm now gonna do it again
but I feel like I'm older now I can I
can handle it yep
was when I was in my 20s and I was being
interviewed by a woman for The Observer
newspaper which is like a very serious
of the broadsheets
it's like the New York Times on Sunday
and I was desperately selling my
grandmother and everyone else I know
because she was one of those Janice that
was sitting with her pen hovered above
her paper not touching pen to paper sort
of waiting for you to say something
interesting and then you get into panic
you more and more stuff comes out
waiting for the pen to start the paper
and I I started telling her a story even
as I began the story I was thinking oh
why am i doing this but basically I
can't really remember the story but I
know that the punchline was ended with
me peeing it myself in a car with my
sister I got to the end of the story and
she didn't know no and her pen didn't
hit the paper and she went she was about
was about three seconds of horrified
silence after which she said um I was
with respect for you Emily I shall never
repeat that story see that's the kind of
thing you can channel when you need to
be scared in wait are you laughing at my
acting this is my my acting this is me
acting scared
that's it it's I'm like us I'm a silent
film star I don't have your hair is
looking terrified as you do that yeah my
hair is I haven't cut it
since the quarantine and sometimes I
just let it go but sometimes when I'm
talking to you know a guest that I am
very excited to talk to I make the
mistake of blow-drying it before I come
on and it puffs up in this humid weather
and it becomes this thing and then you
know it it's ridiculous and I'm sure
it's just terrifying
and also it's structurally unsound yes
[Laughter]
the clip from Relic your character I
mean you feel free to set it up but your
character has come back to a house
yes living you know what happened to
your mother and there's you're looking
for clues and some eerie palpably sort
of scary tense things are happening that
are giving you a bad feeling about it
all is that a fair summation it's a
beautiful summation okay let's take a
look at this clip from relic
what was that okay tonight
and I also want to make sure that I
mentioned don't look deeper yes Whidbey
yes donut deeper on quippy that's coming
out very imminently and it's later this
month
yes thank you I love that I know more
about your career than you do